Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And I'm here to ask you if you kept your promise
And you may be wondering what promise I'm talking about
But oddly enough in the beginning of May, I'm talking about your New Years Resolution
Because I can tell you, if you're starting to get panicked and you're like
"Oh god I didn't do it!"
Well don't worry because I'm here to confess that I, myself, fell off the wagon
If you didn't know, my original goals were to be in the best shape of my life,
to learn guitar and to learn German
The fitness goal, like maybe it was vanity that I wanted to do it
I noticed I was getting a little bit of a belly
And I wanted to just be in general shape which is a cliche for New Year's resolutions
Guitar was just because I played trumpet in highschool
And I know all the stuff about music and I wanted to get back into music and I've always wanted to play guitar
So I wanted to do that just to get caught up in that world again
And then language, German, is because my last name is Fischbach
And that's a very German last name and I thought it would be appropriate
to actually know the language instead of having people constantly ask me if I speak German
and telling them "No"
And unfortunately I have failed in all aspects of those things
And I know the year's not over yet but in the middle of May
I thought I would be at least somewhere close to my goals
And I started to realise why I was failing
And I could make whatever excuse I wanted
I could make the excuse of I didn't have the time or I got distracted or things got in the way
But generally speaking, I realised that I failed in my goals
because I didn't think of the long term aspects of what I was trying to do
Because for fitness, I wanted to be in the best shape of my life just because I had vain reasons in mind
And that's good in by itself, but in terms of being in shape
that's not really an end goal-type thing because if you work to be in shape
and then you get to be in shape and then you stop,
like there was no point in you doing it in the first place, you're just gonna get back out of shape again
That's a life-long thing
You need the proper motivation behind it
And I started to realise after I had a little bit of a health scare again
Nothing is wrong, I'm totally fine
But I live in this state where I have to get routine check-ups to make sure my tumour that I had
before I started YouTube, I have to get checked to make sure it doesn't come back again
And when I was getting my check-up, there was something they found and I had to get it
checked more thoroughly, just to spare you the grizzly details
But it turned out to be fine, there's nothing
But that's something I have to be mindful of
So when I originally went after my goal of getting into shape just because I wanted to look good,
I failed to realise that I wanted to live healthier
Because I never know if the tumour that I had is going to come back
And I can increase my odds by exercising and eating better
and hopefully it'll never come back, but you never know with these things
And with fitness like, it's a lifelong goal
And with language and music, I think I was misguided in what I wanted because I didn't have an end goal in mind
I didn't have something that I really wanted to do with those talents
I didn't have something like, I didn't know if I wanted to perform with guitar or some reason
that I was trying to impress someone with guitar
And with language, I didn't really have an end goal for speaking German
other than it would have been cool to be able to do that
But as far as the language goes, I recently actually realised something that was very very important to me
I talk about my family in Korea a lot
I talk about them like, undendingly
I have a lot of family in Korea
I have numerous aunts and uncles, I have actually 7 aunts
and I have numerous cousins and a lot of them are very proud of what I've managed to accomplish on YouTube
and especially my grandma who I love to death but recently, my grandma had a stroke
and she's doing okay now but this is actually her second stroke
And to be perfectly honest and to put it bluntly, I don't know how much longer she's going to be okay
You know?
Like, it's grim to think about and I hope she lives for quite a bit longer but she's getting older
and this is her second stroke
and the first one that she had left her a little bit disabled
and I have all this family that I talk about all the time and I love very dearly
but I've never talked to them
And that's a weird thing to say, it's a weird thing to admit
I have all this family, this huge supportive family that is so proud of what I've done
and that loves me and my mom is associated with that, she's here in America but they're all over in Korea
and maybe two or three of them speak English
The rest of them just speak Korean
and some of them speak Japanese but not many of them speak fluent English to carry a conversation
And it dawned on my that my grandma that I love very dearly, I've never had a conversation with her
Like I've never really had the chance to talk to her and discover like, her life and where she's come from
and the struggles that she had when she came down from North Korea right before the war
and the border went down and my grandpa, who has passed on, and my grandma,
they abandoned everything they had, they had lands, they had money,
but it was all going to get taken away from them so they just picked up, left their entire family and ran down South
And right now they live outside of Seoul and a lot of you guys are scared
because the situation in Korea seems to be dire but...
my family is down in South Korea right now and I don't know how to talk to them
You know...?
So with that in mind, that is now my reason why I want to learn Korean
And combined, I started to realise that if I take away the things that I want for just pure vanity
and have an end in mind for, and I take on the things that I want to do as lifelong challenges
and lifelong beneficial skills that I will have because
Number one: I will live healthier and hopefully live longer enough to do the things that I want to do
And number two: Learn Korean to be able to speak with my family who supports me and loves me
and hopefully I'll be able to visit Korea again because some of you may not know, I'm half Korean
I don't know if anyone actually, like there are always some people that are shocked to discover
that I'm half Korean but yes, I'm half Korean
and I'm half German
And I want to be able to talk to my family
And I want to be able to talk to my grandma, you know?
And I want to be able to help my mom who is bilingual, she speaks perfectly fluent English
and perfectly fluent Korean
And I want to help her because she's starting to forget a little bit of the Korean because she doesn't have
anyone to talk to in Korean
And I want my brother to be able to do the same thing
So these are the reasons why I've kind of refocused what I've wanted
And if I had to wrap this up in a message for you guys, I wanted to tell you that it's okay to fall off the wagon
so long as you pick yourself back up and reevaluate why you fell off
and then refocus and hop back on
Because it's like, it's hard to just constantly get back up and not change anything of your approach to it
But in this year and what I've wanted to do, I've realised it's so easy to stop when you think there's an end in mind
And that applies to anything outside of this, like what I do here on YouTube
If I thought there was an end, like I wouldn't keep pushing forward and keep hitting it everyday
because I wouldn't want there to be an end and I would think about that all the time and I would think of
"Oh when am I gonna stop this thing? When am I gonna stop?"
It's like, this and what I do on the internet, and what I do in terms of creation,
and it may not always be YouTube videos but what I do in terms of creation and giving
Doing the charity streams, I do it because it's a lifelong venture for me
And I may have an audience or I may not not have an audience or like,
I may be speaking to an audience of 10 people, I may be speaking to an audience of a million people
Like, it doesn't matter because for me, that creation is a lifelong journey of self-discovery and learning
and going forward and trying new things, always always trying new things
and exploring new territory and that is so fun and I'm just, you know, I'm always grateful
that you guys are here along for the ride for as long as you want to be here
But my advice to you is look for the things that really really mean something to you
and use those as fuel to carry you on to your goals
And that right there is going to change everything because I can guarantee you
now that I've focused in on what I really want and what matters to me
And I can still do guitar as a hobby but I don't, until I find some reason to, to really really really pursue it
Like until I find the reason, I'm going to shelve that and I'm going to focus on fitness for my own sake
and in language for my family's sake
And that really does mean something to me
So anyway, I just wanted to share that with you guys, I hope you guys are having a wonderful Monday
I've got a lot of cool stuff, I really am thrilled as the response you guys had to Markipler TV
We worked really hard on that one and I'm just tickled to death that you guys loved it
And you can expect a lot more from the characters that you saw in that video
because we put them in the same room for a reason
And I think you guys are discovering it very soon and you will see it in the future
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down in the comments below
And as always, I will see you in the next video
Buh bye! <3